زياره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف تحمل الكثير في طياتها
فهي زياره الاولى له بعد ان اصبح رئيسا
للولايات المتحده وتتزامن مع قرب الذكرى
الاولى للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا زياره
حملت معها الكثير من الاسئله خاصه انها
زياره غير معلنه ومفاجئه وجاءت بعد نفي
المتكرر من قبل مسؤولين امريكيين الرئيس
الامريكي شق طريقه لكيف في رحله سريه
لاسباب امنيه تم التخطيط لزياره حسب مواقع
مختصه بطلب من اوكرانيا وخطط لها باقل من
اسبوع استقل بايدن طائرته الرئاسيه من
قاعده اندروس في زياره قيل انها باتجاه
بولندا واقعيا دخل بايدن الاجواء
البولنديه الا انه غير مساره واستقل
القطار من بولندا باتجاه كييف في رحله
استغرقت قرابه 10 ساعات وسط حمايه لطائرات
امريكيه حربيه كانت تراقب المجال الجوي
الاوكراني زياره بايدن لم تكن سريه
بالنسبه لروسيا واشنطن نسقت مع كييف قبيل
الزياره لتجنب اي سوء تقدير يقود لمواجهه
زياره بايدن استمرت لقرابه خمس ساعات فقط
وبوفد دبلوماسي صغير تجول خلالها في شوارع
العاصمه كييف وزار جدار قتل الجيش
الاوكراني في الحرب وقدم خطابا في
البرلمان الاوكراني والتقى بعدد من
المسؤولين وقدموا وعودا لنظيره الاوكراني
بمزيد من الدعم العسكري والمادي زياره
بعيد لكيف حتى وان كانت سريعه اعتبرتها
اوكرانيا رساله انتصار وتحذيرا مبطنا
لموسكو
من قلب العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف تصريحات
ناريه للرئيس الامريكي
[موسيقى]
بعث رساله طمانه
الدعم مستمر وبزخم كبير
[موسيقى]